[Music]
so
do
thank you very much um murray do we have
any apologies
sorry michael unmuted um no
as far as i know we haven't got
any apologies i'm just waiting hopefully
for megan
to join the meeting she shouldn't be too
far away
uh i think we'll just do a quick
round of introductions um for anybody
that is live streaming in
so sandra you're immediately to my right
if you could lead off please
sandra you're on mute she's still on
mute
it's actually quite good
thank you sorry
son of stewart womack district council
waimakariri district council
thank you
and uh arapata you uh next on my screen
i hope this is going to work
these muses as well you're wrong this is
going to be a challenge
okay uh kelly you seem to pop up nick
sir
uh hello there i'm kelly simpson uh
three waters manager with the
waimakariri district council
so staff member participating in the in
the meeting
thank you sophie
kirikouto sophia and water environment
advisor at waimaku district council
i'm happy to be meeting again thank you
murray
all uh murray griffin uh cwms
facilitator
for the wonderful waimakariri water zone
committee
from environment canterbury
thanks murray wendy
are you there
just trying to unmute it's all right we
main i'm a community member
thank you wendy john
um john cook and i'm a rooney rep
on the committee aaron
aaron harvey community member thank you
caroline hi caroline latham um
nee williams community member
thank you david david ashby
community member thank you
support
biodiversity officer for zone delivery
environment category
okay oh i see we have tim in the room
tim davey i'm the chief scientist at
environment canterbury and i'm the
acting director of science standing in
for stephanie who
often comes along thank you tim
john john ben just public observer from
the department of conservation
at lee uh adrian is that you there i can
in freshwater ecology and fresh
fresh water and ecology cheers thank you
amber
i'm amber krilliger i'm groundwater
scientist and environment canterbury for
the waimakariri zone
thank you marco
um marco catalonia ecan
zone lead waimakaririnui in zone
delivery
and i'm just trying to see who else
we've got coming up now
um cam are you there
yeah mike yes i'm here i'm multitasking
i'm just driving
home from christchurch so apologies
hopefully i don't cut in and out too
much
that's all right thank you
so cam is our vice chairman
does an excellent job up there in oxford
angus
yorda angus macleod environment
canterbury communications
i believe mr bennett are you there
hi greg bennett uh stormwater engineer
waimakariri district council of lee
and fear you there i have to apologize
as to anybody i've missed because i'm
scrolling through here i think we're
there
you just me sir andrew
saved the best of last thank you michael
yeah kilda andrew arts
zone delivery manager for environment
canterbury or north canterbury
thank you
come back come back
now apologies i've just lost myself that
was good well not here we go
coming back right hopefully i'm back
with you
all righty uh we'll move to item 1.4
which is a registrations of
interest from the committee member's
point of view is there any
changes or additions that they would
like to make to that please
excellent i'll take that as a no
item two which is uh the immediate steps
uh biodiversity update um
support you gave us a fairly good
overview
at our previous meeting is there any
sort of additional information
you'd like to add or flesh out with
these projects please
there's been no new information other
than that i have been in contact with
all of um all four
uh project applicants and they're still
very keen despite all the
confusion and uncertainty that's been
happening that's working to progress the
projects
and uh yeah cool i think that
sentiment is fairly strong amongst the
committee but
uh i'll just open it now if any
individual committee members would like
to comment
on any of these projects and i'm
sorry i haven't got everybody on screen
so just
go for it can i
stand yeah when you put it to the vote
can you put it individually
each there's four of them can you put
them individually please
yes i think that would be possible thank
you
do you want comment now for discussion
or how do you want to go from now
um well i think um if just if there's
if there's any comment you'd like to
make let's let's
kick it around now
well okay well i do have a comment um
i've asked for them to be put
individually because i won't be
supporting
um 1.1 burgess stream the 10 000
going there simply because
it is
while it's a worthy uh quite a worthy
project
i don't see it being worthy of immediate
steps
funding in that that funding is to rev
halton reverse decline of loss of
indigenous biodiversity and while this
is um
worthy rehabilitation and
riparian planting to me it doesn't fit
the criteria
and quite frankly i do believe as i said
before
that this should be part of a farm
environment plan
particularly part of the environment
component of a farm environment plan and
it should be a matter of course that
the farmer rehabilitates
the stretch of stream and does the
riparian planting
which hasn't been the case um and i
do think particularly in the light also
of
um our new freshwater module that's
coming in
with our new reforms that in fact this
will be part and parcel of a fresh water
module that will go into a farm
environment plan
so um it has a low score as zipporah has
uh has indicated because of the nature
of
the rehabilitation it's ten thousand
dollars
for a thousand square meters of
rehabilitation
work um and when you compare to the
other
three on the agenda um we've we're
paying
um we're putting well proposing to put
000 into the springvale wetland which is
12.3 hectares has a
um a score of um
73 percent hammond's wetland equally um
a large area 62
10 grand uh the old wetlands over two
years again
56 and 62 percent um
this one um scores just nine uh 23
so um i've said to uh well before that
in fact that they should be encouraging
their shareholders to put some money
aside or levying through their water
charges
to make sure that um the
this type of stream rehabilitation and
riparian part of
planting is part and parcel um of
good stewardship of the land and also
part and parcel of what is just the
basics
for a farm environment plan or farm
management
so with that i can't support
um burgess stream i'm very happy to
support
the other three but i just want my vote
for those reasons
recognize that it it doesn't
make the grade as far as i'm concerned
for immediate steps though it is as i've
said
worthy of rehabilitation and should be
part and parcel of good farm management
thank you thank you sandra do you have
any other
comments from committee members please
yeah david um yeah michael but i could
um i do support the burgess stream one
um for a number of reasons
i i'm not concerned that it has low
ecological value now and one of the
my little hobby horses about the whole
of ins is the fact that
um it doesn't allow for the budget
and development of native communities in
places where there aren't any
term restoration or renovation um
there are ecological values in the
waterway it's just not the ecological
values on the land of indigenous
vegetation
so um i think anything that starts to um
to restore and regenerate indigenous
vegetation and
animals in the water is important and is
valuable and especially in the area that
this site is
and i do think that um that uh mission
to
um i'm not quite sure of the wording but
um hope the decline
and um is something that goes beyond the
site that
that this is a project which actually
will be
a sort of model for neighbors up and
down streams so that
it might not you know well it doesn't do
everything on that site
i think there will be benefits to
halting the decline and
carrying out restoration elsewhere
i agree that it would be nice if this if
will could um take more money from the
their members and and start to develop
things
um i'd like to think that this might be
a first
indicator of what can happen and make
their members a little bit more willing
to give up some money
and will might make this happen in the
first place and i would not like to see
this as an
as a um as a president but all
will fencing and
restoration comes to us for an ims
funding but
see this is perhaps a kickstarter
probably thank you judith anyone else
yeah just a couple of comments michael
um
i remember us having quite a discussion
around
where best bang for buck was with
regards to immediate steps funding
and there was a clear message coming
from me can that it wasn't for
recreation or restoration or creating
new
they they were rather enhancing what
existing wetlands were already out there
so this one kind of
goes against that understanding
but like sandra i support the the
merit of it but would just like to see
some consistency in all future projects
where there's
it's restoring from old it will
recreating new
yeah it's like to be really consistent
in that yeah so for that reason because
i have you know i have a number of
projects
that wouldn't have fitted under
sephora's
uh direction earlier in the year but um
if we're going to allow for this one
then i'd like to see us consistent and
all other ones
similar to that particularly if there's
um going to be more farmers they're
going to
take take heat of this one and hopefully
do similar yeah
thank you
all right i think that is it isn't it
it's a question of
whether it fits the very specific
guidelines for ims as they stand now or
whether it
fits into the wider benefits to
um as i say plants and animals is
what's you know what's living in the
waterway not just
native vegetation yep sandra
yeah just a question following on from
what um arapada has just said
can staff comment on the fact i mean
this
doesn't fit the criteria and while it's
worthy
and um as judith has said um
you know would like to at a bit of a
flagship for others
what happens if we get a whole swag of
others that don't fit the criteria like
this one
um this immediate steps fund
is quite specific and we're bending the
rules here
for other other values and what have you
and i can understand that though i don't
support it so if in fact what judith has
said happens
where is this what is the staff's
response going to be
to applications that that don't fit
the stringent ims criteria all right
well possibly if the appropriate staff
member could make note of that and
follow up with us
when we have a workshop or at the next
meeting that would be
a valuable conversation i'm just
conscious we are
reasonably tight for time today sandra
so
anybody else
right i'm going to try and flip this on
its head rather than everybody having to
turn their mics on individually and say
that you are in favor i'm going to ask
for
anybody who is against and i'm going to
take the silence
as the affirmative if that's that makes
sense
so the recommendation is that we
the cwms ymca zone committee support
the four immediate steps applications
and i'm going to do these as
sanders requests we're breaking them
down into individual projects
the first one is 1.1 the burges stream
project for ten thousand dollars
no i just like it noted that i support
if consistent with uh for future
projects of a similar vein
thank you
and the silence is carried thank you
uh then we move on to 1.2 the hammond's
wetland project
for 10 000
everybody happy carrie 1.3
uh the springvale wetland project for
14 000.
there and the last one is 1.4
the all wetlands project for 26 000
so those are the four projects that have
been proposed
we seem to have a great silence of
approval
so can i have a mover please for that
erin thank you a second up and you'll
have to speak because i only stole aaron
wave a hand
that was lucky yeah i might involve just
a second
thank you john carried
item three committee updates from
murray what have we got
just moving through
so we've got a couple here
sorry folks i just don't want one i
might try and split the screen so i can
see everything all at once um the
the first one relates to and i can
probably hand it over to our
uh wdc staff members
who may want to speak to this but
we've included this um really just to
give the committee a chance to
provide some feedback on the stock water
race closure at siena place
so the there's a paper included
and libica sent it through
for us to include in the meeting papers
and you'll see in the updates that we've
got to the
30th of june to provide any feedback on
this closure
so we've got two options we can either
provide some feedback directly to libica
by email
or we can note anything in the minutes
of today's meeting which tia
will obviously kindly record so
i'll perhaps open up for any
comments on that or questions
i can give a bit more background murray
just before
any questions or feedback comes from the
committee
so this is a 1.6
metre section of water race at the
terminal end of our scheme
it goes through the um a rural
residential
area um so it's no longer required for
its original purpose of
stock drinking water and i think from
the zone committee's perspective
is the question of um what
impact is it providing in terms of
groundwater recharge
so in 1.5 of the report there's
a basic assessment based on length of
race
indicating that it's about 0.2 of a
percent of our
total stock water length and
total so um it's also an area where we
actually get resurgence rather than
discharge to ground although under
certain conditions discharge to ground
would it would actually occur
uh so with seeking feedback
um any future races that we
look to close we will be bringing
reports to the zone committee as well so
you're aware of it so you've got
oversight of changes that are occurring
um
so we're seeking feedback on this um
and that'll your feedback will be taken
into
consideration as part of the final
report going through to council wdc
elected members for
a decision that won't be until
um later this year probably not until
about october will council
here this final report making a ruling
on that so
happy to take any questions or
feedback to murray
hi sorry i've got a surprise i've got a
question kelly
um just um
thank you for bringing this to us
because i this is quite interesting
i just wondered um obviously first of
all
are there any ecological values in the
stock water race
and secondly and the nature of the
in the reason the individual wanted it
stock water raised closed presumably
they weren't interested in the stock
water side of things
um and then there were some objections
as to why people didn't want it closed
uh yeah so probably the i'll address the
second question first um so in terms of
the people that have opposed the closure
they're more worried about um ensuring
that the closure is not going to
adversely
affect any drainage issues in the area
so that will be a key consideration and
it's almost like a two-step process the
first
is closing the stock water race which
effectively
is a paper exercise and removes the
classification
as a um a stock water race so they no
longer play
rates for the service um in terms of the
physical channel itself um that's the
second
step where it needs to be demonstrated
that filling in the channel
is not going to have any adverse effects
for drainage in the area
so the two people that opposed it
were more a conditional opposition to it
like um provided it doesn't have any
detrimental
effects on drainage um
in terms of the ecological values
sophie might be able to comment a bit
further on this section of race um
that is one of the key things that will
be discussed
in the report going to council um i
don't
know if there are any ecological values
in this particular stretch of the race
um one thing we actually find is at the
terminal end and particularly through
um rural residential areas there's real
challenges with
keeping flow occurring throughout
um you know 365 days of the year
um so that is one of the reasons that
people have actually
uh asked for it to be closed sophie have
you got anything further to add on the
ecological values
oh just just uh to compliment what
you're saying about it being ephemeral
that probably would likely lead to a few
of species that could
inhabit the stock quarter races um i
haven't actually i haven't
surveyed this particular race but we are
looking at doing a wider survey of 10
sites um
coming up shortly to get a bit more idea
around what is in the stockholder races
so um i guess i mean it's my usual
concern is just
did anybody look you know is there a is
there a place in the assessment for
somebody just to go and check
rather than it just being an engineering
ground water exercise
so um i mean i've obviously flagged it
you're obviously aware of it i'm quite
happy with that thank you
uh yeah and just to give you assurance
that is a
we have got a documented process for
closures of stock water races
and considering the ecological values as
part of that as well
thank you thank you judith an answer to
your question i went and had a look this
morning
and effectively there is there's no flow
there at the moment so
um maybe this is a paper exercise to
tidy that up i'm not sure
thank you
hi can i chip in there um if i drop off
i'll put a note on the chat thing but
um i guess my on the face of it
you know i agree it's a piffling little
amount of um
stock quarter race and it's going to be
neither here nor there but i guess it's
the overall principle of it
and that if we keep chipping away at
this
stock quarter system you know is that
going to have an impact
and i just wondered whether when you
survey the um
the property owners are they aware that
that
irrigation and stock water race system
um makes a significant impact on the
nitrate concentrations in that whole
area are they aware of that fact
uh in terms of the first part of your
question i think
um yeah we we are also mindful
that um incremental changes don't add up
to
a total change that then has an overall
negative
impact so to counter that well
we're we have done some work already
looking at over the 20
or the last 20 years changes to the
stock water a system
and how much it's actually changed
so we will actually keep track of that
and we're happy to bring back
kind of whether it's annual or
every second year summaries um to the
zone committee so you can actually see
the net effect of any changes that are
occurring to
uh the stock quarter a system uh i think
in terms of the second part of your
question that
um there definitely are people who
here that are aware of the
benefits um of the stock watery system
but you do get quite a wide ranging
views and
opinions from people you know and some
of them
uh actually like the the people
um in seeing a place you know that
actually um for them they've been trying
for a long time to
get this section of the water race
closed um because i've got something
going through their property that they
no longer use
it's um you know more of a nuisance for
them than a benefit for them
so um yeah i i think
part of education is actually going to
be our broader
education on stock water that is one of
the
um uh aspects that we have been working
on as a council
oh yeah no that sounds good thanks kelly
i just thought you know if you're out
there um
asking those landowners questions um
you know it would be good for them to be
and they weren't aware it would be good
for them to be made aware that actually
the stock water and irrigation races you
know they do make
a big contribution so that they have
that information
to make make their comments on
cool any other comments on that
well we we might leave it up to the
individual members to
submit on that particular issue if they
so desire
murray what else have you got
thank you michael um following on from
that discussion the next item
again just in terms of something that is
currently available and will be closed
by the time the committee convenes again
is the canterbury
biodiversity initiative fresh habitat
fund
and i've included it's page 33
of the gender papers um the
the flyer with regard to that
fish habitat fund and just wanted to
bring it to the committee's attention
that that's
open um four projects
through to the third of july and uh
obviously being very
relevant and topical to the committee i
thought it was good for you to know and
you may well
either know of areas or of people
um who would be interested in in this
information
and this fund and applying i spoke with
chloe armour
my colleague at environment canterbury
um just to confirm
what's the most practical way there is
an application form which i
very nearly put in the meeting agenda
papers until i realized it probably
wasn't that
useful for anybody to have a document
you can't
do much with wallets in a pdf format and
an
agenda so consequently chloe said the
easiest thing to do
if if you or anybody else
does have a project that they're
interested in
seeking funding for then they contact
her and she'll send out the application
form and provide some
guidance and advice on the fund
so i don't know if there's any questions
at the stage that you'd like to ask
with regards to that but it was very
much like the immediate steps
applications just looking to get this in
front of you
in june um
and like the stormwater
[Music]
closure as well that it will be closed
by the time
we convene again
support are you still with us
uh yep still here does that sort of fall
under your
umbrella at all in terms of any
recommendations you've got
yeah so i do work with chloe um
and if anything comes up in the course
of my scoping projects that i go
actually it's not really ims it does fit
better with her fund
then i recommend it to her um
yeah and in terms of um wdc
we got
yeah i'm happy to comment on on that or
sandra if you want
would you prefer so yeah we already uh
last year we put in three applications
for elana's spawning habitat
improvements
and one wasn't able to be progressed at
the time but that's going to be
resubmitted well i think it's already in
for next year
um it was approved but um in next year's
budget
uh so that's the taranaki stream reserve
uh you know a sporting habitat
improvement
just above the flood gate there
excellent
and we are looking at a few other
projects as well so i've been in
discussion with
um with kate and if probably we'll be in
touch with the people at ecan um just to
sort out a few details of whether the
proposals are
worthwhile pursuing lovely yeah thank
you
uh any comment from committee members
sophie um sorry judy here sophia
kate um i was i this struck me that
it might be something to be used in the
pegasus area to try and
discover if the mudfish that were there
15 years ago are still there perhaps
i'll come and talk to one or two at one
of you
um sometime soon just to see if that's a
project that you might be able to
put together yeah the fund is quite
explicitly for capex
um works for habitat improvement it's
not yeah
it's not unfortunately for survey work
it's something that kate and i have also
been discussing we'd love to have funds
to be able to get more knowledge
about but i have done some survey work
in that in that wetland
um previously before my role here so
yeah
and there is a wetland on private land
just off my north road that's been
suggested to me where the landowners
wants to develop his wetland
and trapping in the past has shown no
fish there so it might be a suitable
translocation site
okay but whether that fits this fund as
well whether translocation isn't allowed
in the fund or i think it is actually i
think translocations are fine
one of one of the things that we're
following up at the moment is that we
know that there have been
surveys done sort of um by neewer
and akin previously on
structures and waterways in our district
um and that those were
sort of assessed as to whether they
impeded the fish passage or not
so we're trying to find that data and
get it added to
um nate was uh like fish structures
database
i think i think that might be a good
starting point in terms of
us applying for some of this funding
thanks kate um
i've just stepped into that silence
thinking that might be
um the end of the discussion on that
item unless there's anything else
um any committee members want to race
oh that that silence was me sorry murray
couldn't find my own new button
again um
are a part of is there any projects from
the rooney's point of view that that
might
come in there
yes there are a couple but we're going
to have to
probably bring them up in discussions
next week during our mahita joint
committee
meeting with council yeah okay
thank you
next one murray the next one is
uh our regular if you like where
if you take the covered situation out of
the mix of
um uh meeting update around plan change
seven so just to
we have touched on this from the
committee's perspective and
workshops over the last couple of
months so there's no significant change
at all
from what we've heard previously in
terms of the there is still
yet to be a confirmed date for the
hearing itself
and i've included in this update just
the
the direct reference to that minute
three
that confirmed because of the covert 19
situation that um
the hearing was postponed and that no
further date would be set until we had
greater clarity so
it's really just um an update of where
to get
information that i've provided there in
that
plan change seven update the other thing
too i guess to note is of course that
the
section 42a report is now available on
the on that page as well but
they are the major um
two points i guess at this stage so i
don't know if there's any questions
further to that
yeah murray cameron here um has the
release of a essential freshwater
directional documents
impacting those timelines at all are
they likely to wait for the new mps and
nes before they progress with the
hearing
that's a good question cam and i think
we've got a
included in the
information further in the committee
updates on the action for healthy
waterways we've also got a
statement and angus may be able to step
in here
that relates to plan change seven so i
could have put it
either under plan change seven or under
actions for healthy water waste i think
i've got it
if i can jump to that
i i can talk to that murray if you if
you'd like me tim
um it's always a bit tricky and
the the short answer is there won't be
any delay specifically to wait
for the nps fm um
and the you know the gazetted in psfm
which we're not quite sure on where that
would be but the at the same time
we are acutely aware that the um
plan has to align with the mps fm so
it's a bit of a fine line it's really up
to the hearing commissioners
to work out how that would um occur
but we won't be doing any specific delay
you know to line up with the timetable
thank you tim and the on page 23 of the
meeting agenda papers
under the action for healthy waterways
update which is a
item four i've got um
the question there does the government's
freshwater package
mean planche 7 needs to be changed which
was an faq that was
quickly hot off the press on that day as
we were
collating these papers the
action for healthy waterways were
released so we were uh
um landing that
into the the updates as it was being
written effectively so that that just
provides i guess um
and reinforcing what tim's just said
with regards to yeah i guess the
way plane change seven will respond to
the freshwater package
released by government
are there any other questions on plane
change seven
the stage
i can probably just keep moving michael
in in terms of and i'll deal with
the other the other moving into the the
next
set of updates there it's just there
with regards to the annual report
you're just acknowledging the fact that
you and
cam i think uh represented the the
committee very well
in front of both councils uh
waimakariri district council and
environment canterbury um
respectively over the lockdown period
so um those briefings i think were very
well received by both councils
i don't know if there's anything that
megan appears to
um not be able to make meaning she
is in transit much like cameras but has
struggled to get on so we
tia we may end up recording megan as an
apology for this meeting
she's tried but technology is um
thwarting her at this stage and i was
just
thinking megan may want to comment with
regards to the briefing that michael and
cam provided to the
environment canterbury council i don't
know if sandra if you want to add
anything
in terms of the waimakariri district
council briefing
possibly not no no she's happy
she's happy that's great well look i'll
move on then
we come to the action for healthy
waterways
information i've provided for you which
as i mentioned before
was hot off the press on the day we were
collecting the papers so i
quickly pulled that together as an
overview of the information
for the committee and whoever
refers to the the median agenda papers
just so it gives you an initial
overview of the um the content um i was
going to include
one of or one of the pdfs that was
initially sent to me um but realized
that you'll see in the bullet points the
information for the following are
available that there are a whole series
of pdfs that were available on that
website so consequently
rather than including one i just uh
referenced that and you can
and you've got the link to go to the
page and look at them all so
um and then on to page 23
of the median agenda papers you'll then
see
the faq we just discussed with regards
to how
plan change seven relates at the stage
to the government's fresh water package
and this is tim's
outlined so that was really um there'll
be more information obviously coming
through but that was just what we
collated on the day as we were
putting the papers together so you had
some initial reference with regards to
what the government's released so i
don't know if there's any questions
with regards to that
shall i proceed on michael are you carry
on murray you're doing good
um the next item which we may want to um
have a quick discussion on sandra and
erin have both raised a couple of
good questions with regards to this
update i've received from the
groundwater science team so
to give away the background for amber
and tim who um
will be wondering what on earth i've
done by putting this in the
committee meeting papers i picked this
up from
an update carl henson provided to the
regional committee
and it was um i thought very topical
particularly with regards to this
information now being on the lower side
which i'm sure all the committee members
will be aware of
is uh increasingly being utilized across
the whole country to provide this sort
of information so what carl was updating
the regional committee on
was the fact that this information is
now available
on the lower site so i thought it useful
i've also included it in the kokora
many agenda papers for that reason
i've been the other committee i work
with so
i've included that as just a general
update for the committee
um and i don't know
if we want to touch back now to uh
the the questions that were raised with
regard to this item so we can perhaps
quickly hand it back to sandra and erin
if you'd like to
just touch on those points yeah if we
just got the two
questions that each of the zone
committee members have
they could put them put them forward
murray and maybe
noted um you know i think it'll be
something we need
the staff member will need a wee bit of
time to come back to to answer so
that could be replied to at the next
meeting please
sandra that's fine
sandra and erin are you happy with that
i'll assume
what michael said is fine and that will
enable
amber in particular and myself to follow
up on that for you
yeah that'll be fine i've got some
questions um in
relation to one of the other agenda
items coming up but
yep great
i was just going to ask about um uh
the um 2019 as you see nitrate
uh levels um and i just wanted to seeing
tim is here whether he had any uh
comment to make about the increasing
trend in the southern sites in
waimakariri in the northern area of
christchurch city
or is that going to come together for a
report as
murray's indicated
um well so is that what your question is
that you'd like
some that you'd like it come back on
sandra or was there another question i'm
just a little bit unclear
yes well in the agenda it talks about um
no change in trend
um looking back um to the
2017 um figures but in fact the 2019
um map on your website
um one of those links there shows in the
the wells that are sampled to this on
the south end of waimakariri in the
north side of christchurch
have an increased nitrate trend
which doesn't fit with what the overall
summary is and i just
wanted to understand where that is all
coming from and what is the increasing
trend in the southern
side of the district but i mean if if
if that can come through in a report
that that's fine um it didn't seem to
gel
uh look i i don't think i can comment on
that just off the top of my head so it's
probably better to wait for a
fuller staff response i i
can comment on the um the little change
since 2017 that refers to the nitrate
risk maps
so it means that the maps
haven't changed much since 2017 so this
doesn't refer
to specific wells
if that helps not really but
um thank you uh just um
the um the link that's um with the
report well
in in on the ecan website um which i
can't bring up
to you at the moment um does show an
increased
um a trend uh in nitrate levels on the
southern side of the district in the
northern end of um uh the top end of
christchurch city so just querying that
and whether someone could have a look at
that and come back and
talk us through exactly what is
happening i mean is this
is this what um we're expecting to
happen where we go
get worse before we get yet uh
better are saying plan change seven
isn't really um
in operation at this point so whether
that could be
um uh a part and parcel of a a report um
for
for discussion uh in a future you know
next meeting so
thank you okay thank you sandra
any other questions on that at the
moment
alright is there anything else there on
your committee update the last item
under committee updates is just um
noting that the regional committee
hasn't met
since uh 11th of february and carolyn as
harold does at our march meeting had
provided an update on that
meeting and you'll see that i think
carol and may want to update us on that
but i think they're looking to reconvene
in july
okay all right then uh so i have a
recommendation
that the cwms waimakariri zone committee
receives these updates
um with references to the committee's
2020 work program
and community engagement priorities so
can i have a mover for that please
i'll move that yeah dude a second up
somewhere i can't see if you're waving
at me
i think david david
is using his good arm or his hole down
i'm using my job
hold on good thanks second to dave
and uh again anybody opposed to those
so i'll take it as carried thank you
right item four which is
um the minutes of our previous
meeting march 2010
confirmation
so i have a recommendation that we
confirm these minutes
has been a true and accurate record can
i have a mover please
i'll move that thank you the second up
yeah i think that thank you
matters are rising
sandra thank you um
it just uh perhaps a verbal update
of um you'll be aware that um
in that those minutes michael bates
concerns about the spraying that
um along the uh
waterways and around uh along um
up a kaiapoi in courtney lake um
that and i i would suspect
murray you're going to formally reply
and
minute to the committee
about where that's all at but just
verbally
um both waimakariri
and ecan have been approached
over that spraying which certainly looks
like it's um
done professionally and
neither waimakariri contractors
or ecan contractors
say they were responsible for it so it
remains at this point
somewhat of a mystery and um
i don't know where the zone committee
will go
forward uh with it unless anyone has got
any
any more comment i see jared may have
something to add
um yeah that is correct sandra there was
no record of any waimakariri contractors
or staff
and no record of environment canterbury
contractors or staff
but looking discussion with both
uh waimakariri and environment
canterbury
um we've certainly taken it as a
example to show contractors um
including those that work for us uh that
the you know regarding the care about
what they're doing in terms of spraying
so look i don't think um uh
look yeah i think waimakariri and
environment canopy
have been pretty thorough in trying to
um
find out where uh that what who did that
spraying
um and we're not going to be able to
find anything more now than um
and at least someone comes forward with
some information
so uh yeah look we're not proposing to
investigate it any further
um but other than to make sure that we
do actually try and use that
as a something to from an educational
point of view for people who are working
for us either as staff or contractors
thanks jared
any other matters
corker item five
general business
michael i could probably add reference
to the two items i emailed through to
the committee earlier today
one being an update on the
cwms zone committee review
so at the time that we collated the
papers and in fact uh
it wasn't until friday afternoon that we
had
an update which i've encouraged
the folks to do a monthly update for all
of the committees so
that was available this morning so i've
forwarded it through to you
um we'll obviously look to have another
one in july
so that's really just to give you as
committee members a reference to
where that review is at and where it's
and what the next steps are
so i've forwarded it through to tia as
well so she can include that
as part of the papers if
that's appropriate and the other
item was from anna veltman just
highlighting the um
the drop-in sessions that are coming up
uh for farmers
um in june and july so again just to
enable the committee members to
circulate to anybody that you think
would be interested in those
um so anna was just keen to get that to
committee members so i thought i'd
include that under general business as
well so certainly feel free to
forward that on to anyone you think
would be interested in popping in
sandra uh thank you
uh just a general update as you as
you're aware
um waimakariri has a land and water
committee which
i share um the
council full council last week
bought the kaiapoi river rehabilitation
subcommittee and the cam river
enhancement subcommittee
into the terms of reference for the land
and water
committee so the work program
that is the cam river enhancement
and also kaiokoi river
will come come through that committee uh
now and you're most welcome to come
along it's 9 30
on a thursday morning and we're meeting
physically
on thursday so come along
and i supply chocolate biscuits
oh well in that case
judith um yes i just wanted to raise
something we might
either have a briefing on the next
meeting or discussing a workshop
um some of you will have seen that uh
long tail bats were discovered in south
carolina geraldine
on geraldine's farm last week
depending whether you read stuff or you
listen to country
life they were discovered in the course
of preparation
by a farm in bahrain farm advisor
in the course of preparing this farm
environment plan and
she recommended she suggested that that
might be there and they uh
there should be a survey done before the
plan is prepared
um the alternative is that they talk to
somebody in otop who
thought the bats might be there but
either way it just raised
one of these issues that there are
biodiversity values on farms that are
not significant sites
and not significant vegetation or
whatever um
and as to whether these do get picked up
in the preparation of farm environment
plans
and whether um in waimakariri so
um i know i guess caroline or david who
prepare these plans can help
there needs to be just some sort of
awareness among farm advisors
about the non-significant biodiversity
values
so i'm just raising that as something
perhaps we could um
talk with you know kate
sophie john ben over the next few months
okay i think
it would probably also be really
valuable for the
district council to be notified when
things like that are found
because they probably would qualify as
significant habitat sites
yeah i was thinking of actually the
council knowing
in order to tell the other way around to
tell the camp
the farmers that are land owners not
necessarily farmers these days
thanks yeah there is a bit of a
disconnect judith um
so with the farm environment plans the
the result of the audit goes to
environment canterbury but it's not
not public information about what's in
the farm environment plans
so we don't have to be a voluntary side
from the farmers to willing to share
what they are working on in those
biodiversity sections with
with the district council for example
but it i'm just thinking of how they
in preparing those plans they actually
think oh they might be back
but not you know bats are enlightening
north country world but not impossible
um but you know there could be gecko
living on that kaprozma over the corner
and
just that awareness of non-significant
things that need to be thought of in
managing a farm
but having the awareness of where they
are preparing that farm environment plan
and when it's due for
for review yeah having the information
having a bit of a circular discussion
yeah yeah would be great but i can
understand why there are constraints
with um
sharing that information yeah oh yes
um down south in one of the southern
zones
uh my colleague as fun they did a
um a trial with the consensus team as
farm environment plans came in they
would pass across his desk
and so he was able to review them
because he's worked in the zone for a
very long
time and is very aware of yeah where
things
like bats and and things that might not
get picked up
um uh then he could flag them or go
actually um
i don't think that's been picked up and
it warrants a site visit
um yeah things like wetlands which might
not look like a traditional wetland
um but it is it was it was an excellent
trial and
it's done some amazing things but it was
very resourceful and
it worked because he had such great
knowledge of his zone
um but we're reviewing how we could
do that better
i suspect that there's probably a big
gap there judith
in that um you know that that
what you're talking about isn't
identified in
a lot of farm environment plans i don't
know what dave's experience is but
but i think in order to get um better
engagement there there need needs to be
that direct farmer with an expert you
know like like a
a relatively neutral expert to get that
sort of advice and information
as soon as you put something in a plan
that could then end up on a planning map
somewhere um
you know people do tend to not want to
go anywhere near that
but uh it depends on the you know
somebody like you sort of just even
going well
i need to find out a bit more about this
rather than yeah
but there's a shortage of places to go
and find out stuff
like as you know because i email you
maybe this is sorry michael maybe this
discussion we can yeah i think we'll
carry it on
um in our workshop and because at the
same time it's worth
you know the whole fact that you're now
going to have to start looking at a
freshwater module
incorporated into your plan now i know
the government's still
working out the finer points of that but
it's a similar point of where do you get
that expertise
from in the process but yeah i think we
probably want to keep moving through
this now
as valuable as a conversation this is
so uh murray is there anything else
there you had
i believe that's it michael i think we
might be at the point of
um handing it back to tia yeah i think
we might be into overtime
on our um allotted time frame so
uh and this is anything else that's
pressing there
now is your chance to bring it forward
corker um
mr rubin would you um please do a carrot
here for us please
harry potter are you still with us
he left the building yeah that's all
right
look um in the absence of arapatha
um i'd like to thank you all for your
time today
our next meeting is on the 6th of july
at 3 30 and all things going according
to plan hopefully that will be
in person and sandra might even bring
the chocolate biscuits to that if we're
lucky
thank you very much for putting up with
me and my lack of technical skills on
this but
i think we've covered some good points
and appreciate your time
[Music]
so
you